this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by raycon
upstart and manscaped more on that later
let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we
are over here
doing it in the night pants studios i am
ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media
i can't thank you guys enough for your
support
uh please make sure you subscribe to the
youtube channels you get the audio on
monday
you get the video on tuesday we got the
time codes in there you can jump around
the stories if you want
uh and i want to make sure you guys are
aware if you're not of my patreon show
the honeydew with y'all where i'm
highlighting the low lights
with y'all um if you or someone you know
has a story that
has to be heard please submit at
honeydewpodcast gmail.com
it's only five bucks a month you're
getting four to five episodes a month
depending on how many weeks there are in
that given month and um
it's 60 bucks and i've said before i
know that's a lot of money right now i
know people are on
on unemployment i know things are
uncertain i know
that how hard you work for your money so
thank you for those of you who have
supported
um and also just to let you know there
is a yearly subscription option if you
sign up for a year
you'll save over a month it's like five
episodes or something like that a little
over a month of free content
if you sign up for the year and commit
that way
um please go subscribe to all the social
media the facebook fan page the twitter
account all that stuff
the website for the show is the
honeydewpodcast.com
uh we got some new merch coming uh
there's gonna be some new night pants
are coming
for the fall we got uh the mugs out
there the hoodies i'm telling you they
are fleece hoodies
and the king of fleece will tell you how
good they are it's the best hoodie i've
ever had we got night pants
night shorts i got some new ryan sickler
stuff coming too
so um thank you all for supporting for
wearing it i appreciate you
making night pants nation one of the
best things going out there in
podcasting today
if you live in la and you need musical
instruments or lessons for you or your
kids this is the spot
santa monica music center they have
online classes from la musicians
you don't have to live here for that you
go to santa monica music dot com
you use the code honeydew they'll waive
the registration fee
and give you one free lesson when you
sign up for a package
all right now that that is out of the
way very excited to have today's guest
back on the honeydew y'all the saga
continues
from new jersey ladies and gentlemen
please welcome joey diaz
what's happening ryan sickler it's great
to see you
i know we've been talking but this is
the first time i've seen your face
and uh i'm actually excited that that
you're in jersey where
most of this originates and we're going
to continue this story you good
i'm good all right so what do you want
to plug feeling good
let's let everybody know you got the new
podcast come and tell
tell everybody everything please i got
the new podcast
that i'm i started last week real low
budget
because i can't get all the pieces
everything's running behind
so if i wait for everything i'm waiting
on i gotta because i got a bar set up
i can't start till like [ __ ] november
so i'm just going to go with
whatever what with an iphone a mic
and uh apple and youtube that's it you
know what i'm saying just the basics
to start off but you're looking at the
set i got bruce lee the game of death
behind me
i got deft leopard high and dry led
zeppelin 2
and ac dc the bonfire to the left of me
i'm ready and over on that side of the
office
is the side for the album of the week
for patreon
so i've turned my whole [ __ ] house
into this [ __ ] camera place
so the electrician was supposed to come
today between 12 and 1. he calls it 12
he can't make it till one then he calls
it 110 and says 30 minutes
i said listen let's just do it monday at
8 when my daughter's in school and
so it's just a [ __ ] waiting game but
i'm ready to [ __ ] go
i know so we're just sound proofing now
it's amazon's backed up everything's
about you can't get the [ __ ] in and i
know dude
or you missed no you've got to like
you're doing the right thing
so i'm gonna just get a [ __ ] iphone
best camera in the country in the world
is on the iphone it catches x-rays and
[ __ ]
x-rays you take a picture of the skin
yeah you take a picture of a skinny
person
you see a shoulder bone and [ __ ] with
the [ __ ] iphone it's sensational
it's sensational so why am i [ __ ]
around you put the iphone yeah you get a
mic from amazon
and you [ __ ] go through the box and
that's it you get a second mic
and i got a little setup all this is
communication
and letting people know what the [ __ ] is
going on that's it
why am i making such a big deal about it
the bar i gotta get lights i gotta get a
plug i gotta get a panel
what a [ __ ] nightmare i gotta get
booze this is nice and easy you know
what i'm saying
yeah i know and then these people
complain about these free shows they
have no idea what you got to do to set
this [ __ ] up to do the damn thing
no no they don't know so you know what i
i
i looked at a bunch of people's podcasts
there's people that just put a picture
on youtube with them smiling
yeah and they put a podcast up yeah and
they get 100 though what's the
difference i'll do the same [ __ ]
thing
yeah some weeks if i'm in the mood i'll
let you see me if i get up at four and i
have too much in me then forget about it
i got [ __ ] up last monday by mistake
what do you mean
uh you know me i got a weird tolerance
there's a company out there that has
these hashtags
and all this [ __ ] the suspect i ain't i
ain't bad-mouthing them
they're great they just put houdini
stuff in their [ __ ]
you know i've been around drugs i know
what drugs should feel like
when you take one of these edibles you
feel a little bit different
so i i got some sent out to me and
they're hashtags
and i opened the party with like four of
them you know me how are you [ __ ]
around
oh my god was that
he just kicked it off with four oh my
god
we're four now now i know what thompson
girl felt like on that plane ride
oh my god i was falling asleep
it was terrible we had we had to go out
to dinner with the kids
and like uh one of his classmates and
whether
i was falling asleep at the table it was
a nightmare my wife had to say something
to me tremendous
but every once in a while you gotta have
an accident you know what i'm saying
yeah
it's it's quarantine it is man this [ __ ]
is nuts
it's it homeschools when it officially
puts me over the edge i was doing all
right and then the homeschool hit and i
am not doing okay man i am not okay
no nobody is nobody so she
she she homeschooled today she got out
i got a pizza for lunch and then i took
her for a bike ride
for like 45 minutes you know because we
got the the neighborhood
it's like a [ __ ] one big [ __ ]
driveway it's tremendous
that's what i want to do loving it are
you loving being back in jersey are you
are you how do you feel you feel yes
i'm home i'm home i'm not
living where i grew up which makes it
even better
yeah i go up there i say hello like i
went up there
tuesday i went to my mother's grave
you know i got pissed off because the
puerto rican didn't [ __ ]
mow the lawn i gave him a yardstick and
i told him to take extra care of this
[ __ ] dead stiff
and the [ __ ] there's a big chunk of
grass i thought it was like a snake pit
so thank god i broke gloves with me i
[ __ ]
ripped some of the [ __ ] leaves off
but i got to bring a [ __ ] blow and i
went to get flowers for a grave
and they decided to go on vacation on
september 30th
like can you believe that the day i got
there was that what
they went on vacation from 9 30 to 10
something 10 4 or something like that
i'm like i know they're spanish that's a
jew holiday
like why are they taking off for a jew
holiday they're spanish people
i was pissed off tuesday tuesday was a
good but then i saw
that i went by my buddy's funeral parlor
you know i got a kid i grew up with that
his family has a funeral parlor
they've had it in the family for like
100 years
so i went by there i sat in the [ __ ]
office talked to him for a little while
it was great it was good that part of it
has been great
yeah the part that i'm not dealing with
is my schedule
my schedule's [ __ ] up so i get anxiety
from this
not having a schedule so every day
my schedule gets a little better like
i'm starting to go to bed now at 11
30. it was 3 4 in the morning for a
month
i'm right there with you man i'm a very
uh structured scheduled
person and i'm used to this and this and
this and this
this home school [ __ ] sit there and
help them all day it it
i feel like i'm drowning i really do i i
all good things are happening but it's
all coming all
over the [ __ ] place and this home
school just killing me bro
killing me you know i got people calling
me for this
that i i can't even [ __ ] function i'm
not even functioning 100
i got to be honest with you i got a lot
of anxiety yeah
i get a lot of social anxiety i'm going
to start to do a
comedy residency for the month of
october
at uncle vinnie's by the time this comes
out i'll do the first
you know they see 36 people they
socially distance
and at least i get to [ __ ] get an
outlet once a week
you know it's just 36 tickets that's it
once it's in the door
hear that once again it's in door yeah
it's nothing once a week
yeah that's that's all i got right now
that's all i got right now i got a
family
i got the winter's gonna be [ __ ] cold
here
yeah you know where i live but don't
take a genius if you look on my block
and look around you're like boy
this [ __ ] deer out in september
you know they would deer out when i
moved in on august 31st this is a cold
fast [ __ ]
the way the trees are shaping the [ __ ]
you know when the wind comes in it's
going to be [ __ ] cold so
i'm just bucking down i'm not going
anywhere
there's no plans on any planes or
anything no and i'm just going to prove
i'm just going to provide content
that's it that's all you can do my
patreon the right thing to do
that's the right thing to do and do my
podcast and then get on stage once a
week and
that's the best i could do right now you
know i don't want to go out there and
charge somebody 25
bucks and not have a polished towel
i i'm not close to that i'm doing my
first show in seven months on friday
uh next week uh it's a rooftop that's
sarah
it's a outside rooftop sarah mello puts
on and she's had like neil brennan and
santino and and i
and i hit her up and she's like i'd love
to have you so it's my first one in
seven months and it looks like they're
doing a good job uh with that one
separating everybody it's
open-air venue um so we'll see
i just you know i agree i can't go ask
you for money if i don't have
at least a polished 30 and an 80 other
30 i'm working on you know what i mean i
don't feel right taking it
especially you know people are freaking
out i
hell i even i'd love that's why i love
what you did with your patreon if people
don't know it's a dollar
is it still that is that correct it's
i got to go up to 3 5 10 15. yeah i'm
just waiting for the shirt designs
to come in to give them an option on
shirts and stuff like that
uh the patreon has really taken a lot of
the anxiety away
when i answer those messages i laughed
my ass off
you know they could go either way every
day i get one guy
to tell me that he's in the mood to bust
somebody's head
i got guys that are ready to smack
somebody for me you know i'm saying yeah
they're all over the place are you
getting back
so it's just been yes i
that's my main thing on patreon is the
messaging
i believe that connection is the most
important you know
so it's i i sit there for two hours a
day
when you have 13 000 people that's a lot
of messages
yeah it is so it's two hours of [ __ ]
day
so i wanted to slow it down a little bit
go up to three dollars and uh
just give them tears give them options
give me more options to work with you
know well i'll say this too because i
just did this for myself but patreon now
if anybody out there doesn't know you
can do this for joey too they offer a
yearly subscription
so instead of doing monthly and worrying
about your card getting declined or any
of that you can sign up for a year
so i encourage you right now go sign up
for joey's patreon get the yearly
package sign up for mine the honeydew
with you all get the yearly package
and you'll save some money on it you end
up getting free episodes and free
content so
but again i know money's tight for
people so
i'm right there with you yeah no i
understand that's why i did what i did
and i give you options and uh
you know just to have that connection
you know the other the i think a lot of
social media you look at
just when you read a couple of things it
just pulls you down
you're like really i'm back on facebook
reading this [ __ ] right
i'm back on twitter even though i love
twitter i love torturing people on
twitter
i've cut down a lot i've cut down my
usage a lot since i've been here
so that's because you're setting up
you're setting up the [ __ ] you got
real [ __ ] to do
you know yeah no no here's the problem i
got i don't know
if the story i'm telling you if i was
did i
did i come out on bail or am i in prison
already
i'll tell you exactly where we are
because i listened so it was september
88 you were in prison and you just got
in there
and you said who do i walk into and see
and it's a guy with the two broken legs
that had just jumped out the window
that you'd heard about before and he's
playing cards that's where we are
and i got to keep you in there and and
and the funny thing about that situation
was
but i got accused of that one
right when they were questioning me they
asked me if i knew that guy
so when i saw him at the prison
diagnostic
it made me laugh my [ __ ] ass off it
was crazy
that that time period going up to that
was crazy because i got sent to summit
county first
they told me i wouldn't get the
diagnostic
so they sent me to summit county did i
tell you that yeah and let me just
let me just say this let me say this
real quick for everybody
if so we're picking up i guest hosted uh
joey's church so the story of the
kidnapping and everything is on
a few weeks ago before joey left couple
months ago now probably jeez
um that that story is there
so you jump from the honeydew you can go
to the church get that full episode it's
a two-hour episode it's fantastic about
the whole kidnapping and now we're
picking up with joey
in jail so please sorry continue
okay so i i went from i got sentenced in
boulder
and once you go you know you go into the
cell you start talking about the [ __ ]
knuckleheads and they told you they told
me the system was backed up
that the system was backed up 30 to 90
days
which is good because you get county
jail time you get two days for one
so you want that county jail time you
know
so they they told me that they were
sending inmates to oklahoma and missouri
for the overpopulation in colorado so be
prepared
and they told me all this [ __ ] and i
just yes them to death you know whatever
and the next morning i get waking up and
get taken to summit county jail
that's a ski resort up there like uh an
hour two away from boulder
and i went up there and it was [ __ ]
august and it was just gorgeous out
and i made friends with a kid from
brooklyn and all he did every day was
play handball
my son tan i was brown because i would
play with my shirt off with him
all day long we play handball and he was
locked up
because he [ __ ] had the feds
he told the feds he would cooperate and
buy two kilos of coke did i tell you
this i don't think and he went
he said he set the whole house up
he pulled up in the fed car the feds
waited for him outside
he went into the front and went out
through the back
and took the fed's 30 grand
and him and his buddy left
and they caught him two years later them
four years and they brought him back to
colorado yeah oh yeah
this kid was so i became friends with
this guy this guy was my type of guy
he tricked the [ __ ] feds and they had
the place around it
and he still he did something the day
before where
he went under the fence and threw a
basement and they came out into the car
so they just pulled out like residents
and he was in the back seat it was
perfect
so i became friends with him and i
became friends with his not
friends i became friendly with this guy
you know those guys that always show you
naked pictures of their girlfriend you
ever have those idiots yeah
a lot of kids there's always one [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
they'll go hey come here for a second
look at this chick i'm banging
and they'll show you like a naked
picture that you sent them at lunchtime
or something
well this guy was one of those guys he
there was no cell phones then actually
he just had polaroids or regular
pictures
and all day long she would send her
pictures
of her in a bikini just focus on that
story for now because we're going to
come back to that okay
i became friends with this idiot and
another idiot there were two idiots
i would just say hello to him but he
would always go hey look at my
girlfriend now how does she
now this guy was a [ __ ] mutt and i go
what's your situation he goes
my girlfriend is living with my roommate
now
and she's got my full support and i'm
locked up for three years blah blah blah
so boom i wake up one day and now i'm a
diagnostic
they call me in the morning and they go
pack your [ __ ] you go on a diagnostic
diagnostic is where you go for two weeks
and they go into your head
it's your [ __ ] jungle what do they do
it's real
what they do they give you a physical
they they [ __ ] test you they do
testing scores and [ __ ] like that
yeah you know they they tell you to
identify circles
what comes to your mind when you see a
horse you know
you [ __ ] with their heads it's like
charles bronson and the
and the dirty dozen did you ever see
when charles bronson's a dirty dozen
they tried to [ __ ] with him that was me
yeah so god knows what's on file you
know what i'm saying
right now the feds must think i'm
[ __ ] you know because i [ __ ]
them throughout that whole thing yeah
what comes to your mind
the cuban embassy i would just say
[ __ ] up things so
so it's like five days of testing they
draw blood
and all that [ __ ] and the big thing was
hiv
you know they were looking for hiv
and then you wait there till you get an
assignment
and i wanted to go to rifle there's a
there was a low
uh low risk prison and rifle there was
two low-risk prisons
there was rifle and there was golden
colorado
the home of course yeah so
it was only an hour from boulder i
didn't want to go to golden
i wanted to go to rifle because they let
you ski in the winter
when you were at this prison they let
you
work at the ski resort in the winter and
at the pool
and the movie theater in the summer
no the ski resort and the movie theater
in the winter
and in the summer they will let you work
at a local pool
and what what do they have you doing
like janitorial
like selling pretzels
sweeping the pool lifeguards they were
all prison inmates
that had worked themselves into good
points and now they would be allowed out
to go to do work
so that's a little bit of work release
and then you come back and spend the
night there is that how
yeah got it just yeah it was pretty much
it gets a little easier for you
the only thing golden did was clean
highways
so i didn't want to go to golden
because that's all you do every day you
go out somewhere they put a [ __ ]
cone around you and those are those
idiots you see with the little orange
[ __ ]
best time as you do as you're doing 90
on the 405 i don't need that [ __ ] to get
hit by a car
so i ended up working in the kitchen
they gave me a job and then i got a call
one morning
and they said you're going to [ __ ]
golden i was pissed
even though it was an hour from where i
lived
it would make it so easy not even an
hour it was maybe 30 minutes from where
i lived
you know so my girlfriend could come
visit me my friends could come visit me
family could come visit me you know [ __ ]
like that
so i got the wake-up call to go to
goldman
and it was called camp george west
if you go online you can look it up it's
still online today
camp george west it says an institution
whatever
[ __ ] that it's a [ __ ] prison tell
them
they redid army barracks it was an old
army barracks
so uh i didn't know what to expect guys
you know
i was supposed to go to prison i was
expecting
to be like on a chain gang or something
like that
and here i am in golden colorado
at the [ __ ] old army barracks
you know and they you walk in
you register at the table they treated
you like [ __ ]
you know they'd say something to you and
you were supposed to go to your room and
then
put your stuff away and then right from
your room
you got to go meet with your counselor
so let me ask you a question here you
have a room do you have
are they electronic doors that shut and
lock or are they treating you like an
adult here
and how many people in a room
so they put me in a
like a door uh a barrack right in front
of the office first
and there was eight single rooms
to that barrack and then a shower and
bathroom area
maybe three stalls to [ __ ] three stalls
to piss
and like three showers with curtains
and you had eight guys in there you know
in each one you could visit each other's
rooms
some people had curtains up some people
had beads up like they were hippies
black guys just had a sheet up you know
what i'm saying like they don't give a
[ __ ]
know you gotta knock on the sheet what
the [ __ ]
yeah yo you [ __ ] nuts away dog you
didn't knock out my sheep
what the [ __ ] i got knocked on your
sheets
so it's [ __ ] crazy so uh
that they put me in this one dawn the
first day
and i don't know right away two guys
from new york came up to me how are you
doing
they were two creepy guys but i had to
go to see
i said i had to go see my counselor so
they were talking to me and i'm like
listen guys it's all great
that you're from brooklyn or wherever
the [ __ ] you're from but i gotta go see
my counsel i'll see you when i get back
and i went to see my counselor and he
was supposed to be like uh
they said wait outside his door
and he'll let you know when to come in i
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
so i'm just standing outside his door
and he finally opens the door and he
comes out and he goes
who are you and i go i'm uh
joey diaz jose diaz i'm here to you're
my counselor
and he goes good i was i've been waiting
for you we walked in his office
he sits down he goes let me tell you how
this starts i don't like
fixing [ __ ] whoa so
right off the bat he's like i don't like
space [ __ ]
i'm not too crazy about jews and you
fall into one of those categories so
you get out one of my favorites you come
and see me once a week
yeah he's like you come see me once a
week
you tell me what's going on
and we'll be cool the first time you get
a write-up or a drug test
i send you back to hardware any
questions
get out and i said i was walking out he
goes
have you ever had what's that
[ __ ] that if you cough not gangrene
tuberculosis something yeah tb he asked
me something
because you ever have tv i know do i
look like i have tv
he goes good go see the kitchen they
needed somebody in the in the kitchen to
work
go see mr if you've ever had tb
now usually people prep you they'll tell
you like oh by the way
if they ask you if you have tv say no
because if not they'll make you work in
the kitchen
nobody told me about that one oh so i
was like
no i never had tv so they go see the
kitchen guy he's looking for help
so the kitchen guy was a black dude
maybe six foot six
310 pounds retired [ __ ] marine
whatever he was he was retired from the
service
this guy did not mess around his name is
mr yarber
big brother big burly brother looked
like the coach at georgetown remember
the old coach at georgetown
he looked just like that just like that
dude
i i loved it i loved that [ __ ]
he used to coach patrick ewing
yeah i can't even believe i came
remember uh john
john thompson what the [ __ ] his name
yes mr john thompson
so he mr yarber says to me
i go in there and i had my file my
paperwork in my hand
that the counselor gave me he goes give
this to the kitchen guy
so i gave it to him and he looks like he
goes jose diaz
he goes you go he goes you look like a
baker
because you look italian what
nationality are you
i'm cuban sir he goes cabano that's good
you people put good seasonings in the
food
he goes i want you to be my baker
because have you ever baked before i go
never
because there's instructions there your
first job is cinnamon muffins
i can't believe that you're in prison or
kidnapping charges and you're about to
bake
cinnamon muffins
[Music]
joe you are one of a kind man there
ain't nobody like you
so there's a there's another kid
there's another kid who who got there
with me
who he also made a baker and this kid
and me became tight he was a white kid
he came from a good family and he went
out and got drunk one night
and killed two old people this kid
this kid was like who can i compare him
to like
just think of somebody that likes them
yes and just like steve simone
yeah made a mistake made one mistake he
was a college kid i'll never forget him
because he was so scared and i had to
like hold him and tell him you're gonna
be fine
nobody's going to mess with you we're in
the kitchen now
you know and uh we both got sentenced
like the same
like you know around the same time we
both ended up in the kitchen
and he knew a little more than me about
bacon that's all i know and i was a
little older than he was
he was a real college kid and
we were making the cinnamon one we had
to get
the next morning at lake four and we're
like reading that stuff
and we're mixing you know they have all
this industrial type
[ __ ] so i don't know how to make [ __ ]
muffins whatever they said four to two
two-inch
thing and you put it with a swirl so i'm
like those things look [ __ ]
like little [ __ ] muffins i'm not
giving out those if i'm gonna bake i'm
gonna bake right the cinnamon muffins
so i made these big [ __ ] flying
saucer things
and i started putting them in the oven
he's over here with the cinnabon [ __ ]
box
oh yeah i'm over there trying to be
cinnabon
i never and whatever it called for i
added extra
like whatever flour put an extra pinch
in there
sugar put an extra sugar in there
[ __ ] baking soda i just put extra
everything
and next thing you know the [ __ ] me
and the guy at [ __ ]
were waiting for the first bats to come
out and one of the
one of the cooks was a black guy his
name was chicken hawk
his real name was
i love the nicknames
his real name was spencer antoine
i loved him i loved him since day one he
was a black dude that had a james brown
haircut
but his eye used to wander and he really
was crazy
he took a liking to me he's like what
the [ __ ] is burning
and i go i don't smell nothing's burning
he goes what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
boy something's on fire over there sure
enough
the oven was
setting the fire in the prison kitchen
dude
if there's something black people hate
it's [ __ ] fire
i thought you were going to say burnt
food
blueberries black people hate fire
just from a natural they just lose their
mind when there's a fire black people
it's in their dna
i love i love you to death
african-americans
but you light a fire under that
african-american
they'll run [ __ ] quicker the kkk is
for chasing
these brothers these brothers
all the kitchen workers there was no
mexicans in jail
at that time that were in the kitchen it
was it was us
it was it was us two white guys
and everybody else is african-american
in this kitchen
and they run out they don't like fire
they run the [ __ ] out
so white boy the college kid actually
picked up one of those [ __ ] fire
things
you know with the snake with the dust
mm-hmm and he's over there like [ __ ]
hitting them with dust and finally the
fire went down
the muffins were burnt half the oven was
burnt
mr yarbrough came in he's like mr hose
mr mr jose diaz obviously i made a
mistake
i thought you italians were experienced
like i told you
i wasn't italian i told you i was cuban
because i thought you were messing with
me i wasn't messing with you
i don't know how to bake all right so
don't make me a [ __ ] baker
so he fired me and the white boy he goes
you guys are fired
so he goes all right i like i think he
fired you
that's the only god of fire he's alright
right right like he fired
[Laughter]
it made him it made him skittish you
know
it meant like kind of trusting and not
trusting but then he realized that we
were the good kids me and this other guy
so he goes i got a position that opened
up
that you guys would be perfect for to
when he was having a driver's license
and the other guy you know he murdered
two people he got no license i think
he's not even allowed to go on a scooter
and [ __ ]
i had a license believe it or not i had
a license
so he goes okay i got a job for you guys
he goes you're gonna i'm gonna be the
stock clerk
so i'm in charge of ordering food
making sure that everything is is
stocked well vegetables
milk rice meat potatoes
the other guy was in charge of the lunch
for the [ __ ] guys that go out
and uh pick up pick up trash on the road
so he was in charge of making their
sandwiches and finishing
and doing the bags i would help them
some mornings
and i also got in charge of driving
the sandwiches to the guys
oh so you'd be like you'd be like their
uber delivered
you delivered the food to the highway
workers
oh my god you know what's so funny all
these years i've seen those guys on the
highway and never once have i thought
what do they do for lunch or how did
they get lunch
and that's what happens you drove them
lunch you you're oh they probably love
seeing your ass
i [ __ ] dare it was a dirty lunch it
was like a salami cheese sandwich
an apple a thing of milk
maybe a bag of chips you know but
you gotta also remember here's a lesson
for people at home
those guys that are cleaning the roads
they're also picking up drugs
because they find them out the window
and [ __ ]
no they find out the night before what
where they're going
and they'll call out and go ryan sickle
do me a favor tomorrow
i'm going to be working on the corner of
colfax and riverside
hide something somewhere and let me know
where you hide it in the morning
i'll call you an hour and you would say
there's a little bush
i put in the bag next to a beer can
pick up the bag and throw it in the
garbage and make believe but there's an
ounce of coke in there or
an eight ball of coke that's how drugs
go into the prison
a lot of drugs go in through uh
you know guards but although fifty
percent of the drugs go into those
street crews
you pay off the guard that much so they
don't search you that much
yeah yeah a bag of coke at mile marker
six
i love i love the criminal mind
that's why whenever you're making a
u-turn and you see something weird
stop the car and pick it up you don't
know what it could be
you could end up like yeah like tony
blandetto and the sopranos when he found
that bag full of money with crack
yeah yeah found like 300 that was the
same [ __ ] thing that was for somebody
else so i did
and it was it you know i think about
that time
my time in that place i was in that
place from september to february
in the six months let me ask you this
because i want to know this you you
you're obviously in there with people
who've killed people you've said
um who's who's the baddest [ __ ]
you saw in that prison who was the guy
that you just did not [ __ ] with was
there one of those guys
and then and also did you ever get
tested
those are things i wanted there was a
god the two things that happened to me
there were great
because when i first got in there i was
pretty much
independent but i had the kitchen crew
behind me
and they were all african-american the
leader of that crew
his name was chickenhawk okay antoine
spencer
he was in there for uh involuntary
murder like involuntary homicide
where you pull out a knife and i pull
out a knife and you go to stab me first
and i stab you
so it was like a a questioning type
murder yeah he stabbed the guy three
times or whatever
he was a tough guy like his rap sheet
he had done 16 years he was going home
now you know
the bikers had a halfway tough guy that
at the time
i forget what his name is but i'll
remember it by the end of this podcast
real wrinkly face you know pug nose guy
he had a reputation as a hard hitter
there was a couple bikers that ran and
then they weren't
the white guys that hey there was a
couple of those guys
but the baddest guy in that system when
i was in there
was a white guy by the name of john
clark
he really had a couple of murders
he was just ending a big stretch
if i was 26
he had to be about 42 and he had spent
like the last 20 in jail
vice and a bunch of guys and [ __ ] like
down the street
he had come from philly
um and he befriended me
we became friends so i had coverage from
him
i had coverage with the brothers and
that's all the coverage i needed
you know yeah there was there was a
couple there was a couple mexicans i was
friends with that they ran by themselves
uh but that was that was the strength
my friend was a my best friend in prison
was a [ __ ] okay it was a big
time [ __ ] we became really good friends
and my other good friend in prison was a
blood
so we became really good friends so we
because i was in the middle of it those
two guys spoke
the one and they were both interesting
guys the one guy's sister
was just running in the olympics the 88
olympics no [ __ ] she was
really popular yeah she was the really
popular black woman
african-american woman is that jackie
joyner
was that her
one of those that was two of those
sisters
yes one of those was a brother okay
and the cr and the [ __ ]
his name was toray and he was
my [ __ ] brother in there like me and
him were together
24 7. we worked in the kitchen together
we ate together you know he had
seven girlfriends
and he would schedule the visitations
all of them from
monday and tuesday you think i'm [ __ ]
kidding fake david to come
he was naked he was
the head of moving cocaine from la to
colorado
that was his primary job for the crips
he was
loaded with money loaded
he had seven women and each of them
all of them were driving hot cars
and all those cars were his he had
kids with all of them he was my age he
was a millionaire
and he would he would make all his women
bring him nutter butters
so at night him and i love not about his
like a [ __ ]
he loved nutter butters that brother
loved nutter butters
and he was beautiful he looked like
michael b jackson the guy that played
on rocky michael that's who you are
that's what you look like michael b
jordan whatever he looks just like
michael b
jordan just all ripped up and gorgeous
oh and we used to laugh i used to make
him laugh
you know he was just at night we'd watch
tv
he got a tv in his room we all had
little black and white tvs
but his room he had like speakers he
rigged up and stuff
so i had my strength came from
running the stock because i had my own
independent
stock shed about a half a mile away from
the institution
so i could hide stuff for prisoners so
when the dogs would come
they would never bring them out to that
shed
so once a month dogs came through the
sheds and they would find syringes and
stuff
but if you hid your stuff by me you
wouldn't
the dogs wouldn't come out there so what
i started doing was i wouldn't hide
nothing
in the shed with the food and the
freezer
i would hide stuff outside the property
cameras wouldn't see so i would hide
like
heroin syringes heroin
steroids cash
if you wanted to hide your cash because
you weren't supposed to have over twenty
dollars on
you so
i had cash in there also i used to hide
because i ended up with a little chubby
italian guy
he was a gangster from one of the
families he was on a tail end out too
and what he did was he ran the pool
thing
so he did it for college football pro
football and monday night football
you know those pools that you run like
50 cents
when's your like like 20 bucks yeah
so i became it was just such a great i
became partners with him
i said to him he because he used to cook
every night
he was the jailhouse cook he made nachos
every night
maybe he made hot dogs he made hot dogs
at the buns already around them what do
you call those
those little pork pork in the blanket
yeah he would he would he would take
he would take an iron that you iron
shirts and you take the guts out of it
and you put it in a [ __ ] bowl with a
piece of cheese
and that's how you melt the cheese you
stir it
so he would start making green chilies
like in the morning
at six with cheese and by eight o'clock
there'd be 20 [ __ ]
standing outside these army barracks
waiting to buy nachos to watch tv
[Laughter]
it was hilarious sound all right
yeah for real so i told him i said i
said listen you're only gambling
and you're only getting through to a
couple white guys
if you let me part be partners with you
i'll get the black guys involved i get
the spanish guys involved
and that's exactly what happened so i
doubled his action i went from them
doing one card per game
to three cards per game forget about
sundays
i would have them on every game so i was
split we were splitting the profits
so i think we'd make like eight bucks
per card each
so i was making like you know three
cards a night
24 hours plus i made a dollar forty an
hour in the prison
i was living like a doctor you know what
i'm saying
i was moving from town to town like
segura you know what i'm saying
[Music]
i was moving i was moving every three
weeks like tom segura
[Laughter]
and then you're stashing this cash and
steroids and all this that's come
funneling into you you're hiding it off
property out of camera
and then they come to you to get like
sort of the general store almost to get
their [ __ ]
is that how it works so they would come
to me
to get like uh to hide stuff for them
so i knew what was really going on
behind the scenes there you know
i knew you know like john clark that
dude
he would his girlfriend would come on
mondays
and he would make out with her and she
would pass a balloon onto him
and he would put it in his mouth and
that balloon was filled with speed
mech at the time so he would go back to
his barracks
and we'd do a line of piece and then
we'd go to about on mondays you were
allowed to go to the basketball court
in the high school close by and play
basketball
me and him would go in there on speed
and just go [ __ ] off in there on
monday i wouldn't sleep till wednesday
every week and i was pissed testing you
guys they would do surprise piss tests
but they couldn't catch certain things
like they weren't going to run a
spectrum
on you they were going to test you for
what what drug you came back
you went to prison for with me it was
cocaine
so they would always test me for cocaine
you know
so i did even like the holidays didn't
bother me in there
like i thought i was gonna have a real
hard holiday in there
the holidays were [ __ ] great man
number one
ah number one i can't even believe when
i'm here oh
it was one of the best christmases i
ever had in my life
we gave each other we gave each other
presents and [ __ ]
because there was this we we were we
were allowed to go to the store
every day you had 20 minutes to walk to
the store and come back
all right this is exactly like um i had
a laundry camp that was at um
it was a laundry camp a minimum security
facility for guys just like you
right in right by me where i lived it
was uh on this mental institution
property it was part of their acreage it
was this back corner
and every now and then you'd hear a
siren because one guy would
get out of there or whatever but i went
and watched their softball team
the dirty socks but we would see them
every now and then they'd be at the
corner store because they'd be allowed
off the property and they'd have to go
back
so i'm i'm this is very much like what i
grew up near we'd see him over at the
baseball field and [ __ ] [ __ ] around
or whatever so
this is interesting to me this is what's
going on with these guys in there huh
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor raycon
i've been listening lately to podcasts
i've been listening to ymh i'm listening
to rogan i'm listening to two bears one
cave i'm listening to josh potter's new
podcast as a matter of fact
all of my raycons and my spotify music
uh and if you're using a pair of premium
wireless earbuds especially if you can
get them at less than half the price of
the other guys
i'm recommending the wireless earbuds
from raycon okay i've used them to
travel work out everything they stay in
they're good the base is solid the
recharging case is fantastic there's no
weird
cords and uh you know
knobs hanging off the end uh and
everybody's trying to borrow from me
they take my steps on i told you took
the other pair i had
but their newest model which is the one
he took the everyday e25 ear buds are
their best ones yet they have six hours
of play time
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass a
more compact design
a noise isolating fit raycon earbuds are
stylish they're discreet
the company was co-founded by ray j and
celebrities like snoop
mike tyson brandy and everyone is
obsessed with their products right now
so give them a try raycon has a 45 day
free return policy that's awesome
for a limited time you get fifteen
percent off your order
at buyratecon.com honeydew that's
by buy raycon r-a-y-c-o-n.com
slash honeydew for a special 15 percent
discount
on raycon wireless earbuds make sure to
check it out now while the deal is
running by raycon.com
honeydew our next sponsor is upstart now
during these economically turbulent
times everyone's looking for a way to
feel more financially secure
so if you're still needlessly throwing
money every month at high interest
credit card debt it's time you checked
out upstart
the revolutionary online lending
platform that knows you're more than
just a credit score and now is the time
to find out how low your upstart rate
can be
to help pay off high interest credit
card debt unlike other lenders
upstart can reward you based on your
education and job history in the form of
a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or a diploma to
apply though upstart lets you skip going
to the bank
because it's completely online they
offer loans from a thousand dollars to
50 000
so you can consolidate your debt into
one easy fixed rate payment upstart
makes it fast and simple to check your
rate and since it's just a soft pool
it does not affect your credit score the
hard pull happens if you accept the rate
and proceed with your application and
the best part is if the loan is approved
and accepted
most people are getting their funds the
very next business day
over 400 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals free yourself from the
burden
of high interest credit card debt and
get back to using your money
your way with upstart see why upstart
has a 4.9 out of five rating on
trustpilot
and hurritupstart.com honeydew to find
out how low
your upstart rate can be checking your
rate only takes a few minutes
that's upstart.com honeydew
our next sponsor is manscape now listen
up fellas
we have a new manscape product alert
manscape just released the weed whacker
which is a nose and ear hair trimmer i
want you to take a look in the mirror
right now and i guarantee you're going
to see some hairs
sticking out of those holes it's time to
keep your ear and your nose hair looking
as nice as your clean
shaving pubes i don't know how many of
you ever had that that hair sticking out
and you wish you had something i've used
nose hair trimmers that suck and pop
that thing out and your eyes start
watering you get that one weird like
ear hair and you're like where the hell
did that come from manscape is forever
changing the grooming game with their
weed whacker their nose and ear hair
trimmer provides proprietary skin safe
technology which helps prevent
nicks snags and tugs in those delicate
holes the premium manscape weed whacker
uses a 9 000 rpm motor powered
360 degree rotary dual blade system
its intelligently contoured design
enhances the trimming experience and it
is waterproof
which makes for easy operation and
cleaning the only nose hair trimmer on
the market with a powerful and
rechargeable lithium-ion battery that
lasts for up to 90 minutes of use
you ever tried to pull that nose out
with your fingers yeah that's going to
hurt worse than nicking your balls
okay manscaped is making whacking your
weeds a time to look forward to
delivering maximum confidence
while providing hygiene look fellas 79
percent of partners polled
admitted that long nose hair is a major
turn off ain't
it's time to upgrade your manscape
routine with the weed whacker get
20 off plus free shipping with code
honeydew
at manscaped.com thank you manscape for
keeping our pubes trimmed and our hairs
and our holes
looking nice that's again 20 off and
free shipping with the code honeydew
at manscape.com one more time y'all 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code honeydew what are you
waiting for go whack your weeds
now let's get back to the do you had 20
minutes to go to the store and back and
it was
a five-minute walk so basically you had
10 minutes to go into that store
buy ice cream potato chips milk whatever
you wanted
so i figured out something there was a
little chinese joint next to the giant
i used to ask people nobody ever gets
chinese food outcomes
they're like because you don't have
enough time no you guys got to call it
in
so i started calling in like little
orders like
fried rice and like you know shrimp food
young
egg food young or something and i would
get there the food would be ready
i'd run into the bodega get two things
of coca-cola
and i'd run back so i was eating chinese
food in jail
it wasn't the best chinese food in the
world but at least it gave me a little
bit of normality
me and uh torrey piles we love the pork
fried rice in that place
and he loved the chicken wings so i
would get the fried chicken wings
so sometimes i would run over and get
fried rice
and then torrey would go and buy like
300 [ __ ] chicken wings
like there was like six wings for 395.
he would get like 50 wings
the prison didn't know what they we had
in that bag
it was great there was no liquor store
around there so they really wouldn't
look in your bag
and you could see the store from the
guard house
so you could see if somebody met you for
drugs so they really didn't
they didn't really watch i remember the
first time i walked back with chinese
food
that god was like i've been here for
[ __ ] 10 years
nobody has ever brought back chinese
food how did you do it
and i thought i planned ahead i called
in for 10 minutes before i could get
over there so it actually sat for 10
minutes
before i could get there but there was
age was big then aids people didn't know
how to handle aids
so they built they built a special
barracks for the guys who had hiv
and they only had three or four guys
with hiv
i still i could still see their faces
that's how much i hung out the hiv unit
because the hiv had a brand new tv
brand new refrigerators brand new stoves
they could cook their own food in there
so we all figured out a way how to bring
food in
cook for the hiv guys and they would let
us hang
in that thing they weren't none of them
or they were all hiv
because they were intravenous users you
know i think one guy was
gay but nobody ever gave him a hard time
he was just one of the guys you know
and we we'd i remember sunday nights
going over there and watching marry with
children and cops
that was our [ __ ] yeah cops you lived
all week
for cops on sunday night you lived
for cops but something interesting
happened to me in there
and this is where everything changed for
me
since the minute i got in there
people would always ask me hey
did you get your paperwork from
the uh those the first portion
i called it of the first two weeks
before you went to prison
before i went to the camp i went to that
place do you remember what i called it
the uh the first two weeks
whatever it was i can't remember that
you're getting double time you're
getting double time out there
not only no that's count but
when you got into yeah yeah what did you
call it
it's called something because when you
go there that's what they determine how
many points you're at
how many points i won't remember what
you called it but
where you're eligible to go to you know
whether you have a driver's license
whether you had a job at the time of
your arrest
whether you had a high school diploma
all these things counted towards where
you were gonna go
if you had over three points
you would go to a minimum security
prison
you know how many points i had minus one
and a half
so how did you lose so i was eligible
i was eligible for a halfway house
right off the bat i was eligible for a
halfway house right off the bat
remember my sentence was 48 months
but there was a house bill house bill
1200 1204 1200
that if you were a first-time offender
and your sentence not what you were
arrested for
what you got convicted of was
non-violence
you your sentence would be cut in half
so what i did was one of the guys got
out
he was the law house clerk
so for three or four weeks i studied
really hard
i got a book and i studied all the laws
and i took a test and guess what i
became a long time
so i was the stock clerk i was the
[ __ ]
the guy who drove the sandwiches and now
i was also
the attorney at the prison so when
somebody got a write-up
i would argue with the guards and get
there like basically
like the shop steward of the union for
the prisons right so i became one guy
you're the representative
so i became that guy and i [ __ ] won
every case
did you win them all oh i won them all
dirty clean whether i got to them on the
side and talk to them
you know i would tell i would talk to
the guy who wrote the [ __ ]
report and nail him down a little bit
and throw him off and you know i had a
good relationship
with a lot of those guards there was
some guards that were just douche bags
but a lot of them they were human beings
and i knew how to tap into that side
you know what i'm saying so they were
okay with me
but the guy i never won over i i i
i won him over slowly to guide this
counselor i had
mr blue i was about to ask the one that
didn't like anybody
yeah so i got there probably
the beginning of september but by
november i had softened them up
by november i had softened up the whole
place
i'm not gonna look you in the eye and
tell you i was running the place
but off the record i kind of was because
i was running the gambling
i knew where all the dealers were i knew
they were hiding their stash
i didn't mess with their stash i was
always respectful
i charged them a nice amount i was fair
i also told them what food to eat what
not to eat
which they really appreciated you know
if i knew a guy was a bodybuilder
i got him extra milk and i give him the
nice cuts of meat
so he could cook him on his own i
learned how to you know what i'm saying
i learned how to take care of people so
now people took care of me
you know i did it on the rogan podcast
once
if the food if they would serve you
[ __ ] on shingles what is that called did
you ever hear that expression
it's corn yes [ __ ] on a shingle yeah
like hash or whatever yeah that [ __ ]
not not corn beef hash it's called uh
beef something but what it's called in
the army and all that stuff
is [ __ ] on [ __ ] yeah my dad taught me
that from the military
yeah [ __ ] on shingles so
[ __ ] on shingles whenever they served
that i would sit behind the line
of the food and it would be like chicken
hawk would be serving
edgy this is a tall skinny brother
six foot three he was like a junior at
one of the colleges
wide receiver michael irvin looking
all-american he went out to a bar
he went out to a bar and punched some
guy the guy died
in the hospital that's why you got to be
that's why you got to be careful with
your hands
yeah but so you had ecchi and then next
to edgy on the line
was this other dude and he was a bank
robber
all right he was a professional bank
robber and him and his brothers were all
bank robbers
they were black they were
african-american
but he was funny because his job in the
kitchen was part time
he only worked the night shift but the
day shift
he would be there for lunch and it would
be a smaller crowd
because the other half was out working
picking up papers
so he would always come up to me and go
cuba cuba
let me highlight you for a minute and i
would go what
i go what's up they go is mr yarber
going to be in the
in the in the kitchen at lunchtime
i go sometimes he's in there sometimes
he's in the
stock room double checking my
double checking my work he goes listen
here brother
he goes listen i got to work on my
freezes
i'm like what are you talking about he
goes man i'm going to be free in about
90 days
and i got to work out my freezes and
[ __ ] because if not my [ __ ] is weak
he goes one time my brother had the flu
and he went to rob a bank
he tried to yell freeze and his [ __ ]
crack so people didn't pay attention
you got to keep
he wasn't going there to practice
hollering freeze
with commands
his brother had to yell freeze a second
time
because the way he goes the way you yell
freeze
is very important because it's got to be
a word a certain one
it's got to come out of your throat a
certain word and people react to it
because i got to practice my freezes and
[ __ ] all right
coming to the kitchen so sure enough
he'd wait till
he went
he'd wait till everybody was alive they
all had their plates
in their head and he would jump down and
he would jump in the back door with an
imaginary shotgun
and go freeze [ __ ]
nah that was that didn't really let me
do this again
he's coaching himself out there oh my
god and there we go
oh god i don't want to tell you what the
black guys would say though
the black people offended them the most
the black people were so offended by the
african-americans and yelling them and
say
what the hell is the matter with you man
get your [ __ ] together brother come on
man grow up and he'd be like what i got
to keep my freeze game tight
he was dead seriously his freeze game
let me tight you have no idea
how much i laughed in there but then
then i dirt
wednesday and thursday night was movie
night
and they would play the worst movies in
the world
just like what are you getting like
you know [ __ ]
what's the movie what's the greatest
movie of all time
like black and white like [ __ ] like that
like black and white stuff that
african-americans and convicts don't
want to see that [ __ ] they want to see
the terminator
they want to see rambo black people love
rambo
do not ever get confused
all right hate fire love rambo bro
they love rambo they only hate listen
black people only hate fire
if it's going to them they love it shot
other people they go crazy
they love it they love it
[Laughter]
[Music]
so for me going off in the kitchen
because i would go off on the kitchen
when they would come in there was bad
food
i would go don't do it
that's all i would do for for minutes at
a time i would just go
don't do it
[Music]
don't do it mr yarbrough look at me go
jose diaz
why do you keep saying don't do it for
they won't eat my food
i'm not saying that i'm just saying
don't do it
just for me thinking it's the thing i
used to stop being a criminal
so he's like i know you're lying to me
boy how come he's eating my beef
how come nobody's eating the chicken
today you know like he would always
attack me
if i would say don't do it or whatever
and i would always go off on that mr
yarbrough relax man what's the big
problem look at that [ __ ] would you eat
that i don't see you eating mr yarbrough
so all those kitchen guys saw that
so on wednesday night or thursday night
was projector night
we would watch those stupid movies pt
109 and [ __ ] like that
like a bunch of black and white movies
and the projector would always break
so one day i just got up
and i'm like i'm sick and tired of this
thing
the state's got so much money when are
you gonna get a new [ __ ] projector
and all the guys like give it to him
cuba that's a boy give it to him
and that's how it started and there was
like an
african-american dude that was one of
those red dudes that had freckles
and we would goof on him he was a great
guy
he would let us we would call them
freckles and [ __ ]
and they would all get up and and say
you know cuba get up there whatever the
projector would break
that's what happened the projector would
break
the tape the the film would break
and people would people would go cuba
get up there
get up there get up there and talk tell
us about the week
and i would go anything about [ __ ]
edgy [ __ ] giving you mashed potatoes
with no butter
and he'd go [ __ ] you [ __ ] and i
go off so it started like a weekly thing
they would say
go on go up there and do 10 minutes
and i would go up and do com i was i
didn't know i was doing comedy
so wait uh yeah i wanna i wanna is this
the first time you'd ever
really got up and performed in front of
a crowd at all
it was in prison there wasn't a stage
there wasn't a microphone there wasn't
nothing but you're just up there
talking to these guys and talking to
these guys
but you remember what i told you on the
podcast we did on the church
no about the guy that i worked with
at subaru that didn't like me me and him
had gotten into an argument
and one day he came up to me and he goes
i don't know if you know what i did
before i came to work here
because i worked in las vegas in the
entertainment business
and he goes between you and me i think
you should get into stand-up comedy
his name was his name was grant fusmet
and i remember looking at him going you
know what you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but i remember going home and just
thinking about that
that maybe i was a comic
so now here i
am eight months later and i'm actually
doing comedy in a weird
sort of way but it's not registered
yeah it's not registering with me
one day the counselor my counselor saw
me
doing that one night there was one night
a month he stayed there late
and this was this particular night and
it was probably like a
november night it was after thanksgiving
going into christmas i remember like it
was yesterday
because i was walking out
and for weeks i would bust his balls
about the report from diagnostic that's
what it was
diagnosis thank you i'm so focused on
you said remember the guy that showed
you the pictures of the girlfriend in
the bikini and i haven't wanted to
forget that
this is just horrible to think of but
you have to think about it
from this perspective i kept asking him
yo tell me what's on my diagnostic
report
tell me what's on my diagnostic report
and he would look me in the face and go
you don't really want to hear
what's on your diagnostic report because
you couldn't handle it anyway
and i kept busting his balls busting his
balls busting the balls
and one of those nights that i went off
i caught him
and i'm like just off adrenaline i got
in his face a little bit
what are you going to tell me what's on
that report and he goes you really want
to know
and i go yeah i really want to know they
just come with me
and he went in his office and he [ __ ]
went in his desk and he pulled out
a file and he threw it on the table and
he goes you want me to [ __ ] tell you
what it says
he goes i'll tell you what it says and
he started reading
the psychological [ __ ]
and he goes he took off his glasses and
he goes in other words
what this says to me is that you're a
deadly individual
it says that if you want something
that i have you will do
anything that it takes to get that thing
so a person should just give you
whatever you want
so from now on when you want something
just
ask for it because if not you're just
going to take it from them anyway
and i remember looking at them going
thank you for telling me
i'm just a piece of [ __ ] thief i
appreciate that
and he looked at me and he goes i told
you you weren't going to be able to
handle it
i didn't talk to him like three weeks
after that
that blew all that fun i had all that
fun i was having
came to an end because i realized now i
was in prison
and i realized i was a piece of [ __ ]
that i was just gonna end up a [ __ ]
thief
so i would see him and i wouldn't even
go to his meetings anymore
i was getting out of there in february
anyway it didn't really matter
so one day i was walking in the daytime
and he saw me he goes what happened
you lost your balls ever since i told
you the truth
and i go no i just don't want to hear
that [ __ ]
i'm just a [ __ ] thief he just come
here for a second
because you obviously didn't understand
what i was saying to you
and i go what what are you saying i'm a
thief and he goes no
i'm telling you that you're a deadly
individual
because whatever you want in this life
you can get it
because you're running this chuck and
jive nickel and dime [ __ ]
because you don't think i know about it
because you're a [ __ ] genius compared
to these guys
because i don't think you understand how
dangerous you are
that if you want something it's yours
you could just take it you know and that
resonated with me like just
just it just destroyed me because he was
right
he was right you know like he and then
i had a system i didn't work at an eight
hour day
i went in that eight of course you did
you know
you know me dog i worked like a two-hour
day
i went in i basically went in the
morning made sure the guys had this [ __ ]
if you know anything about me i'm well
prepared they had this [ __ ] the night
before early you're there early and then
the
trunk would be filled already with the
sandwiches i would help him out
i would go through the gate a guard
would get in with me
we drive together we talk [ __ ] we drive
they take the sandwiches out we go back
to the [ __ ] thing
it'd be nine o'clock by then and then i
would shoot straight to the library
and the library was a white dude that
looked like josh potter
he was also from buffalo he was in there
for double murder
he murdered holy [ __ ] he murdered his
wife and the mailman
which made it a federal offense they
were
but
he was like josh's father and
he was very intellectual he was very
smart he wore
glasses he rolled his own cigarettes
and like i had maybe three weeks left
and one day i went in there they gave me
a black notebook
you know the black and white notebooks
the regular ones where you put your name
your grade and your address he gave me
one of those with a pen
and he goes that's uh
a notebook for you so you can write your
jokes
i go i don't write jokes he goes
wait a second whenever you go up there
on wednesday nights
that's just you talking i go yeah i
guess
i don't have time to write jokes i've
never written a joke in my life
you go so you don't sit down during the
weekend well you see me i'm in here
reading sports
and arguing because i would go in there
would be me him
and chickenhawk chickenhawk was in there
for involuntary murder
and he was african-american but he was
well-spoken intelligent as [ __ ]
so we'd go in there and just talk about
whatever was in the newspaper it was
like three convicts
talking about the world's events and
[ __ ] and i learned a lot from those two
guys those two guys were [ __ ]
a lot smarter than i was you know and he
gave me the notebook and he goes listen
i'm going to be out of this hole in two
years if when i get out you're not a
stand-up comic i'm going to hunt you
down and kill you
i would take that as a serious threat
so you know i went back to the
mr blue and i apologize for my behavior
and a few
on january 20 1989
my case went back up in front of
the uh there was a president who got
inaugurated that day
january 20th 1989. i forget what i think
it was bush
one of the bushes yeah you have to be
right yeah
um yeah i wouldn't in front of the uh no
no no no senior senior what am i saying
yeah i went up in front of the board
and they gave me community corrections
and i think uh by february
13th i was in bctc
the halfway house in boulder
and that's a whole different story
that's that's what we pick up next time
from bc that was my whole prison
experience
so i had a really good time in prison
and i prepared myself to go in like i
lifted weights i swam
i rode a bike i knew what things i was
gonna do and what i wasn't gonna do
and the experience was completely
different from what i thought it was
gonna be
like when i came out of prison it was
completely different
than what i thought i was gonna be i
didn't see anybody get raped
and yes there was one guy that didn't
mess with me
he was a young guy that hung out in the
biker crew
and whenever he was with his biker
friends he would make little
comments at me
so i let my friends know what was going
on
and they said whatever it is we got your
back so i had
john clark's crew which they were uh
nazis like little neo-nazis that's the
other thing
john clark was pretty much a neo-nazi
like he had like a swastika
i figured that yeah i figured you're
gonna survive in prison for 20-something
years you gotta go drastic
yeah he he loved me for who i was
we would talk about cube all the time in
fact that's how
that's how he became tighter because the
lady who raised him was cuban
his mother is his like his uh babysitter
was cuban
so he told me how much food how much he
liked the cuban food
and that's how he became friends and i
remember snorting speed with him
and seeing the swat sticker so i had his
support
and i had the black guy support if i
went to war with this
biker they told me exactly how to do it
they said just get him one-on-one
don't involve the bikers and one day we
were listening to guns and roses that
just come out
remember i got sentenced as sweet child
of mine had taken over the world
so now it's november of 88 and uh
november of 88 november rain and and
and and guns and roses is everywhere
that first album is huge and i remember
getting into an argument one of the
bikers about mr brownstone
that was about heroin he goes it's not
about heroin
and i go it's about heroin and that's
when that kid started to argue with me
what do you know
you hang out with blacks and all that
i'm like oh you dumb [ __ ]
so the first thing i did to him was
he would torture me a little bit i knew
i could [ __ ] him up
but it was quick i would i would get
killed
if i ever got caught in his area of the
yard
i would get killed because there were
like two guys
that in that crew that i didn't really
like the leader
obviously i told you i can remember what
his
dog some raw dog or something like that
was his name
he was a disgusting guy and him i didn't
like the long head guy
so i knew if i i knew i had to take him
out eventually
at some point but i also knew
that i had a secret weapon that he
didn't have which is the mind of joey
diaz
i'm gonna [ __ ] break you down
mentally [ __ ]
so he had a job in the kitchen so i
didn't torch him in the kitchen
i left the kitchen alone because i could
just [ __ ] him up in the kitchen it would
be easy
with the blacks around me and nothing
would happen the black dudes would help
me
what i did was i took a american cheese
box
you know the cheese the government sends
you i took the box
i took the cheese out and i took a [ __ ]
in that box
i took the biggest [ __ ] you ever seen in
your life it had to be like a 19-inch
[ __ ] that broke together
i took paper towels and i put it in the
box
and then i took a little they had like
little american flags
in the workshop i took a little work and
i put it in the piece of [ __ ]
and i put i covered the box and i put it
in this drawer
and i put his clothes over it
and every day he would stop us on the
way and go oh
does anybody else know [ __ ] and we would
go nah i don't know nothing
and he was like i swear to god i snow
[ __ ] somewhere
this one this went on for like a month i
was just taking american [ __ ] boxes
taking shits off and then i would put
him in the ceiling he had ceiling tile
that you could pick up every other
ceiling towel
had a box with a piece of [ __ ] in it
and eventually one day he found the one
in the drawer
and it had gone from 19 inches to about
six and a half
all the moisture got out of it it was
just down to peanuts and a couple
clusters of
of hair and whatever the [ __ ] a couple
of corn clusters and [ __ ]
dog heath fly there he's like
he's like somebody's somebody's messing
with me i'm gonna
find out who it is and [ __ ] them up and
all this stuff but
there was a gym area and the gym area
was a room that was next to the laundry
room
and they had a billboard up in that room
about jobs or events
or situations or programs you could get
into or whatever
and one sadly i'm working in the kitchen
and i see him by himself
walking into that area to drop off his
laundry
i go this is when i get this
[ __ ] today
i thought i remember it was cold out so
it had to be like january
february but the sun was out it was a
really pretty day but it was
cold so i waited
for him to go back and get his clothes
and i told the black guys the only
people who would hang out in the gym
were the black dudes that would play
dominoes
so there was a bunch of guys playing
bones and they would listen to bobby
brown's don't be
cruel don't be don't be i was gonna be
grateful so they would [ __ ] when
bobby brown would go up the room would
light up
and they would throw the [ __ ] bones
it was great but in the daytime they
didn't play it was just a couple of
brothers that would lift weights
so i waited till the guy went in and i
went to the side door
and brother i caught him as he was
taking the clothes
from the dryer from the washer
and putting it in the dryer i just stood
behind him
and the wall next to us had the
billboard on it
with all the events that are gonna
happen he [ __ ] turned around
and i was right there on i go you still
got that problem with me
and before he could even say anything
i grabbed my hand in between his hair
and like that's why i've never liked
long hair and i grabbed his hair i
locked him in like a
i didn't know anything about muay thai
it was really it was really like holding
somebody
doing muay thai holding their neck and
kneeing him i didn't even know that
stuff
i just did it with his hair i grabbed
his hair
and i dragged him over and i banged his
head off that billboard
possibly 20 times like that was
that was that was the only bad thing i
did in there
i banged his [ __ ] head like 20
[ __ ] times i mean boom boom
boom boom he went down he woke up
he never said nothing again and he was
three doors down for me
we were in the same bunk because we both
worked in the kitchen he never said a
[ __ ] word
he knew i told him when i was banging
his head i know the next time me and
john clark will [ __ ] kill you
so don't ever speak up around me again
because he would always throw a little
remarks and [ __ ]
after that when he would see me he
wouldn't say two [ __ ] words
i still remember this kid what he looked
like he was a white kid with long hair
and big
[ __ ] lips he just he just wasn't
even normal
that [ __ ] poor [ __ ] wasn't even
normal
they would probably give them [ __ ]
transgender pills or something at the
time to poor best
but that's it wait hold on that's not it
because i have two quick questions you
said
about the dude showing you the bikini
pictures of his girlfriend you said hold
on to that remember that for later
why what what is that come back
okay so i get to the halfway house
i'm uh i'm working at boulder toyota
no i'm working as a detailer
and
i get out of the halfway house my child
is born
and i hear boulder the city of boulder
is on alert
because a guy escaped from prison
in canyon city and he was headed to
boulder to get his girlfriend
it was that idiot damn
summit county that had broken
that had broken out so what he basically
did was
he broke out of jail because she let him
know
that she was sleeping with his roommate
yeah
who didn't see that coming he got so
crazy
i guess he did he broke out of a medium
security prison like
i i won't tell you the story how he did
it because i don't remember and i would
just be lying anyway
all i do know is he broke out of that
medium security prison
stole the car and went to boulder he
went to uh
i think it was somewhere off of lee hill
road
and he said he saw four kids target
practicing
shooting guns so he went up to them with
a fake wallet
and he goes i'm a wildlife guy put your
pistols down i want to see
identifications
the kids put their weapons down he
picked up the weapons and shot the four
kids
and took their guns and money [ __ ] and
went into boulder
he went into kmart which i lived across
the street from at the time
and he bought ammunition they had proof
of them
so they locked the city of boulder down
they knew they had a wild guy i went
home and it was on tv
i couldn't even tell my wife or anybody
i was in jail with him
like i i was in county [ __ ] jail with
this idiot
so i lived on 30th
close to baseline i lived on 28th street
if you went to like 32nd street in
boulder
on your way to longmont there used to be
a jazz club there like a blues club
i don't know what the name was it was 30
[ __ ] years ago
this story i'm telling you happened in
1990
or not even 91 but let's say let's leave
it in 1990.
so this idiot broke out shot the four
kids
set up a meeting with his girlfriend to
meet her at that blues club
and got into a shootout with the cops
jesus one of the one of the cops shot
him in the neck
there was a problem the guy lived but he
needed surgery
guess what the problem was the only
surgeon available
was the father of one of the kids he
shot
no [ __ ] did those kids die by the way
all those kids die
yeah we can look it up jesus we can look
it up yeah
i think two of them died two of them
survived
i think he refused to take care of the
dude
and the dude died or something weird
happened
they had to go to court something right
now doesn't
i talked about on a podcast once how
weird of a story that was that
he the guy refused to operate on the guy
because he killed his son that afternoon
so that's the world i saw man
it's a [ __ ] crazy way first of all
thank you
you know i love you and thank you for
making time for this because i know as a
parent
what's going on in this world i know no
it's important um
but i want to uh just wrap up so when i
listen again i know i said
where do we february excuse me february
88 we're going to pick up march 88 we're
going to pick up
you're out of prison no we're going to
pick up
february of 89 when i get into
the halfway house bctc
so you're going from prison into this
halfway house
so now we're in the halfway house for
the first time and this is the fun part
we're going to pick up
this one harry this is the one that puts
bleach pellets on my dick
to pass the piss test this is all fun
all right february uh 89.
so by now listen joey's joint should
have like two experimental podcasts out
by now
we're just gonna rough it the first
couple of weeks until all the parts come
together for our
studio and then we'll move into the
studio but for now i'm just going to
start a podcast
right here with what you're seeing with
this face and we're just going to do our
thing
until the wheels fall awesome well i
love you brother
and uh thank you so much and uh thank
you to all your
people you got it we'll do this once a
month
you know me dog i don't [ __ ] around
patreon.com
joey diaz stay black you bad
[ __ ]
don't forget uncle vinnie's wednesday
nights
in october 36 people so you got to buy
your tickets fast
that's all i gots say hello to everybody
ryan i say cool
you know i love you [ __ ]
as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you